de joven coronel del ejército francés a
héroe y símbolo de la resistencia contra
los nazis así se dirigía a yaoundé gol a
sus compatriotas de la francia ocupada
desde londres donde winston churchill lo
vio refugio desde el 17 de junio de 1940
creemos que el honor de los franceses
consiste en continuar la guerra junto a
sus aliados y estamos determinados a
hacerlo
rechazando la capitulación del mariscal
peta google que por entonces era coronel
grababa en los estudios de la bbc- los
mensajes de aliento que lo hicieron
célebre y alimentaron la llama de la
resistencia francesa jefe de los
máquinas como se llamaban los miembros
de la resistencia el general fue el gran
artífice de la liberación de parís y de
francia en 1945 en parís
parís parís indignada parís rota parís
martirizada pero parís liberada
después de la guerra el gonismo se
convirtió en una doctrina una corriente
política que llevó a google al poder a
finales de 1958 mientras francia
atravesaba una crisis de sus
instituciones con su llegada de gol
proclamó la quinta república un régimen
presidencial hecho a su medida en sus 10
años en el poder
google conoció la época económica más
próspera para francia conocida como los
treinta gloriosos pero también la larga
y cruenta guerra en argelia y la
descolonización de áfrica marcaron su
mandato
finalmente la juventud del mes de mayo
de 68 y sus huelgas hambrientas de
cambio frágil izaron la posición del
general de 78 años envejecido y
confrontado al grito de la calle ella
ofrece a popeye lo vi la gente quería
ser dueña de sus vidas así que querían
ser dueños de la calle de la fábrica
pero no querían ser dueños del poder
me pasa por el puma al año de gol
terminó marchándose del poder tras un
plebiscito fallido el resistente símbolo
de una francia apegada a su soberanía y
su grandeza falleció el 9 de noviembre
de 1970 en su eterno hogar de colom
venidos de gris a donde este año como
cada año desde entonces acuden
presidentes y líderes franceses a rendir
homenaje a un personaje que más allá de
las polémicas es considerado el político
más importante de la francia
contemporánea